Ron, Jesse, we're sending
you back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history--
[music playing]
--the Inigo
Montoya-inspired rapier.
You know the guy. (SPANISH
ACCENT) You killed my father.
Prepare to-- forge, all right?
[chuckles]
Today we are pre-testing the
Inigo Montoya-inspired rapier.
This is a version of
the Inigo Montoya rapier
that I love from
"Princess Bride."
So many people are
inspired by pop culture,
by seeing different blades and
different weapons from movies.
Now to actually see a version
of that, that's amazing.
Now, guess what, Doug?
You get to test it.
Yes.
WIL WILLIS (VOICEOVER):
Considered one
of the greatest swordsmen
of his generation,
Inigo Montoya is a fictional
character from the cult classic
"The Princess Bride."
According to the story,
this famous blade
was the finest sword ever
crafted by his father.
In parallel, Spanish swept hilt
rapiers of the 17th century,
featuring a diamond
cross-section
and a complex elaborate guard.
Intended for dueling, rapiers
are lightweight and feature
a narrow point,
allowing for quick cuts
and deadly, accurate thrusts.
One of the most recognized
sword fights in pop culture,
Montoya infamously
uses the weapon
against his father's
killer, fulfilling
his quest for revenge.
When you think
about the rapier
and how people wore
it in those days,
and thinking about
the movie, it inspires
you to try to move like them.
One thing that I love about
this is the posture of the way
you wield the weapon.
If it was like a dance--
the dance of balance,
the dance of posture--
and to be able to
move and to wield
one, but at the same time,
be like this very proud man
that Inigo Montoya was.
The unique feel of the rapier
is that is a sword for dueling,
mostly for dueling one on one.
So by having
something that light,
and you pull it out, you should
be able to wield it nicely,
move around, not lose balance.
Some weapons you see
out there, you can tell,
these are just
butchering weapons,
I mean, for mass
meleeing and fighting.
But you can see also
that there's some weapons
that are created for finesse.
Sometimes they say,
sometimes you're a butcher,
sometimes you're a surgeon
where everything you do
is with a light touch, but just
as deadly as one that is very
wide in its chopping motions.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
JESSE (VOICEOVER): I'm about
to start building a Inigo
Montoya-inspired rapier.
There's not a
whole lot of room
for error, so slow and steady
will be the name of the game.
But I would really like to be
through with the blade today.
The guard is very intricate,
and it's going to take
a lot of attention to detail.
And the sooner I can get on
it, the better off I'll be.
Here in a minute, we're
going to start getting
ready for the heat treat.
I'm really worried
that a blade this long
is going to come out warped.
This is the make
or break moment.
So we're kind of
at a mystery place.
We don't know whether
it's hard, and we don't
know whether it's straight.
I noticed that there was just a
slight little yaw in the edge.
Fixing to take all that
out in grinding today.
Next, I'm gonna
move on to the hilt.
I'm planning on
forging all the parts
for the hilt out of
an old wagon wheel
that my grandfather used to own.
I'm going to try to
make up a little time.
I'm going to go ahead and
forge out a knuckle bow.
And hopefully, by lunchtime, we
can start fabricating the hilt.
This hilt's been
pretty demanding.
There's about six
different pieces here.
We spent a lot of time trying
to make sure everything
was dialed in.
My hilt all came
together pretty nicely,
just pulled it out of the etch.
Everything looks good.
My boys have popped
in to see us.
MAN: Daddy, he's the one that's
taught us everything we know,
so.
That-- you'll never
hear that again.
That's the only time
they'll ever admit that.
[laughs]
[iron clanking]
RON (VOICEOVER): I am
almost positive that they're
going to do some kind of a flex
test, so I'm choosing ADCRB2.
That should help with that.
The hilt is one of the
more complex pieces here.
I'm actually going to use
some really old wrought iron.
RON (VOICEOVER):
One of the really
nice things about wrought
iron is that it's beautiful.
My plan is to acid
up so you can see
the lines around this thing.
I'm working on my normalization.
This is make or break.
If it works well, I'm all set.
I grab hold of it with another
pair of tongs and go for it.
I am very pleased right now to
have, at the end of day one,
a quench blade ready for temper.
But my goal is to actually
get done with the blade today.
It leaves me two days to work
on all of the embellishments.
I may get into doing some
of the hilt work today.
I want to see how it
goes with the grinding.
If I overgrind, I could
completely destroy the blade.
There's a reason that it
took Inigo Montoya's father
a year to make this sword.
There are so many
pieces to this.
Now I can focus on getting
that really complex
handle and hilt all together.
I'm forging out these
bigger rings that
are on the side of the hand.
That's eventually
going to become
this really complex basket.
Not perfect, but for
day four, I'll take it.
Regardless of the
outcome on this thing,
I've had a blast making this.
Win, lose or draw, it's
just been so much fun.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, Daddy Bladesmiths.
My name Douglas Mercaida.
I will kill the dummies.
They are prepared to die.
[chuckling]
To find out what
kind of lethal damage
your weapons will do, I
will take your rapiers
and deliver some
thrust and slashes
on this ballistics dummy.
Ron, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Absolutely.
Let's do it.
[music playing]
All right, Ron.
Let's talk about
your rapier here.
It is a little bit
on the heavier side,
but it's wieldable.
And with a nice swish of
a slash, it cuts deeply.
Overall, sir, your
rapier, it will kill.
Good job.
- Thank you.
All right, Jesse.
It's your turn.
You ready, sir?
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
All right, Jesse.
Let's talk about
your blade here.
It's about the same weight.
The thrust penetrate
all the way,
and to slash, well, deep cuts.
Overall, sir, your
blade will kill.
Thank you, sir.
That's what I came to hear.
DAVID BAKER: All
right, gentlemen.
It's time for the strength test.
And yes, I am going to
torture your blades.
Ron, you're up first.
All right.
[thump]
If you haven't guessed
already, it's a flex test.
[music playing]
Good job.
OK, Ron.
That's a brutal test,
and he did really well.
If you look at
your blade, there's
the slightest of bend in one
direction, barely noticeable.
The dimensions of the
guard are spot on.
And it's definitely
a strong blade.
Nicely done.
Thank you very much.
Jesse, you ready for this?
'Bout as nervous
as a long-tailed
cat in a room full of
rocking chairs, but go ahead.
[laughs]
[music playing]
[exhales]
First things, Jesse, the
guards in the proper scale--
really nicely done.
Issue is, you picked
up a bit of a bend.
Still completely
functional, usable blade.
Well done.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, this
is the sharpness test.
This is all about how
sharp your blade is
and what it does to this dummy.
Ron, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[cracking]
All right, Ron.
Let's talk about your edge here.
This cut through the clothing
and right into the foam.
And of course when
thrusting, it goes deep.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
- Thank you.
- All right, Jesse.
It's your turn, sir.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
Let's do this.
[cracking]
All right, Jesse.
I can still see the little
bend it took at the tip.
But the edges are razor sharp.
On the thrust, it goes deep.
It will cut.
- Thank you, sir.
[music playing]
Ron, Jesse, you
guys have turned
in some really quality blades.
This is a difficult
decision for us to make.
And our Forged in
Fire champion is Ron.
Congratulations.
You are the new Forged
in Fire champion.
Jesse, please
surrender your blade.
JESSE: Not being
the "Forged in Fire"
champion is kind of-- it's
not what I was looking for.
But if I made this
blade again, I
would have took a little
more time on my heat treat,
made sure I had it perfect.
Ron, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
You've led your family
to this position,
and you'll be taking
home a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
- Thank you.
[applause]
It feels spectacular.
From beginning to end, this
has been a great experience.
So the Hardman house
is getting the "Forged
in Fire" Championship.